[Musique]
sur le radar des décrypteurs il ya
disons un modèle des informations qui
semblent avoir eu beaucoup de succès de
parfaits inconnus sur youtube avec des
discours à forte saveur
conspirationnistes je sais pas si vous
vous rendez compte on en train de nous
dire aujourd'hui que c'est un nouveau
virus
on se fout de la gueule de qui que ce
soit pour nous faire croire que la
technologie 5g et responsables de l'aco
20 19
ouais que le nouveau core anna virus est
une arme biologique redoutable
faites vous votre propre opinion pour
savoir si le coronavirus est arrivé par
pur hasard ou s'il a été délibérément
utilisé comme une arme biologique
militaire que le milliardaire bill gates
a tout manigancé ou que les
gouvernements ont fabriqué la pandémie
de toutes pièces vous voyez bien que les
chiffres sont trafiqués qu'on essaie de
manipuler pour augmenter gonfler
artificiellement le nombre de morts pour
justifier des mesures politiques
ces vidéos en cumulé des centaines de
milliers voire des millions de
visionnements et elles suivent tout le
même modèle ou presque
un homme assis devant la caméra vous
explique pourquoi tous les scientifiques
les gouvernements et les journalistes
vous montrent ce coupé complètement des
médias mainstream
ce serait déjà une très bonne idée façon
ce sont des mensonges
qu'est ce qui pousse de nombreux
internautes à les croire sur parole
c'est la question que s'est posé mon
collègue et jeff y ait une partie de la
réponse se trouve dans le contexte très
anxiogène dans lequel on se trouve
selon catherine amyot professeur
titulaire au département de psychologie
de l'université du québec à montréal
les périodes de stress ou d'anxiété
amène certaines personnes à perdre leur
balise à être moins critique envers
l'information reçue et à rechercher un
message clair rassurant qui va leur
permettre de donner un sens à ce qui se
passe autour d'eux or ces vidéos
conspirationnistes sur youtube offre
souvent des réponses simples faciles et
claire même si elles sont fausses
la deuxième affection est beaucoup plus
mortel que la première
autre facteur à considérer l'adhésion
aux théories conspirationnistes est
souvent associée à une méfiance marquée
envers les autorités
selon marie-eve carignan professeur
département de communication à
l'université de sherbrooke
cette méfiance peut pousser certaines
personnes accorder davantage leur
confiance un quidam sur youtube qu'aux
scientifiques donc dans cette vision des
choses
un homme anonyme dans son salon en train
de parler de sa vision des choses et
pour certaines personnes plus dignes de
confiance que le professeur d'université
qui appartient disons une certaine élite
catherine agneaux souligne qu'un message
prend parfois de l'importance et de
l'ampleur si on peut s'identifier la
personne qu'ils communiquent
oui la nature exceptionnelle de la
période qu'on traverse explique le
succès de ces youtuber
conspirationnistes on verra bien si
cette tendance va se maintenir une fois
la pandémie passé pour en savoir plus
sur l'analyse du phénomène proposé par
jeff y est
rendez vous sur le site web des
décrypteurs salut
[Musique]